the Joe Rogan experience I did actually
talked about you on my first one so when
I first did your podcast it was this
story out that Joe Rogan is a badass and
he choked out a mountain lion and I was
like I don't want to go talk to no white
man and shot a [ __ ] mountain lion
that's a made-up story I know but I
didn't know at first and I was so scared
Joe that was a mountain lion killer like
I was out there choking line I'm used to
black people doing drive-bys I used to
white people just choking out of metal
rock so I'm trying to figure out how to
[ __ ] he get up on the mountain line any
[Laughter]
hype and sneak up on a mountain lion
from behind and choke the [ __ ] out of
him he gotta be strong as [ __ ] so I kept
digging and I realized the store wasn't
Rozzie huh I don't know why due to choke
you know I see you a big old wait is it
that big old horse yeah well I know he
killed that [ __ ] mouth like it's a
colossal meats realized it took about
two about a mop before I realized the
store was my old sister didn't think my
own sister thought it was real really
she texted me she goes you really choked
out a mountain [ __ ] is wrong with you
you bad ass I mean only you can sneak up
on a mountain lion I don't think so well
I run with a knife when I run I carry a
knife with me just in case because
there's mountain lions in my community
really yeah yeah they've seen him yeah
and I run with my dog and the mountain
lion tries to jack me or my dog I won't
have something on me
so you you if he jack you know you're
gonna stab him [ __ ] yeah
you know I was just telling the story
about my you know I'm from the south
right so back in the day and don't get
offended people but you know dog
fighting is big in the south so we
didn't fight like no dangerous [ __ ] we
just put some down leaders on the ground
who have a dog getting the best they win
in LA
well my dog was named pup pup now we're
later you like candy now and laters
the candy candy so yeah have the dogs
fight over candy yeah me my daughter use
a split leak and whatever get some candy
that wins what black dollars you eat
anything back there
collard green pig feet whatever black
black people in my dog food so we will
meet my dog will fight a lot but if you
got the best of my dog I would jump in
and whoop your dog gasps my old lad
German Shepherd then I'll be calling
every time I'm abusive to town because I
don't own no [ __ ] dogs I got faux
crack babies and I don't have an animal
this was back in the day and I was a
little girl but that's what we used to
do it is a big thing in the South period
I knew a guy who had 30 pit bulls in his
backyard he had these boxes like that he
the dogs lived in these little dog
houses and they were chained to a post
and they were in his yard and I didn't
see it my friend was telling me about it
but I knew the guy and yeah he lived
down he lived in Kentucky yeah you lived
in Kentucky and they fought dogs well we
only did with just kids we whoever dog
get the best of whoever dog they winning
now right so if I thought pup but what
about the guilt go down on his back I
would jump in and put your dog in a
chokehold cuz I like wrestling I will
fix ya I was thick and photos [ __ ] out
of your dog I was not losing them now
later Joe we didn't eat a lot I can lose
my only meal that day your only meals
now later some day it may pop up we sit
on the sidewalk we whipped his head he
will pop up and we'll split the now
later Wow
there's a lot of people right now listen
like is this lady for real and I can
assure them that you are I'm for real
yeah I've had a crazy [ __ ] life you
know
[Applause]